it's official Taylor Swift is a
billionaire welcome to the a tour her
AAS tour alone is a party generating
hundreds of millions of dollars it's a
multinational conglomerate with the
world's most devoted customer base and
an ultra charismatic
CEO never before have we ever seen an
artist put multiple stadium shows on
sale in the same city and blow them all
out but how much of the money has gone
into that CEO's pocket we've crunched
the numbers to come up with the most
definitive account yet of Taylor Swift's
wealth and here it
is Bloomberg has a team that tells up
how much the world's wealthiest people
are worth it's based on careful
calculation and Analysis of all their
income and
assets Taylor has become a billionaire
not just because people like her songs
but because of a lot of smart business
business decisions that she's made over
the years Taylor Swift is a phenomenon
but she's hardly the first billionaire
in the music industry there's the record
label Scion David geffin there's Jay-Z
Rihanna the late Jimmy Buffett and
plenty of others while those
billionaires use their Fame as the
foundation for other business ventures
Swift has made her Fortune almost
exclusively from her music she has
really come out openly about the
importance of controlling your music and
owning your music as an artist so where
exactly does her wealth come from let's
start with streaming the rise of Spotify
Apple music and others has created a
Resurgence in the recording industry we
estimate that her total income from
streaming is 175 million clearly not a
number to sniff at but one reason it's
not bigger is because of the way
royalties are
distributed typically what happens is
artists don't own the masters of their
music but they get royalties from it it
the owners of the Masters generally keep
4 fifths of the royalties while the
copyright holders the composers and
lyricists keep the rest so what Taylor
has done recently and has been a very
smart business decision is to re-record
her albums and then own the masters of
those so this re-recording exercise
she's kind of taking back control of her
music she's reclaiming ownership of it
but she's also diluting the value of the
Masters to the first six albums that are
originally out there Swift also took the
battle to the streamers themselves so in
2014 tellor Swift pull all of her music
off of Spotify she did it in protest of
what she said was um unfair compensation
from the streamer that gave her the
upper hand when she renegotiated her
rates to join Spotify again in 2017
she's also done a great job in promoting
fysical album sales online uh through
Twitter Instagram other social media
Networks
so fans have an incentive to buy
physical records she's leveraged social
media and kind of connecting with fans
getting to know them on a personal level
sharing information about herself kind
of creating this intimacy which has
created this really really powerful fan
base who connect with
her Bloomberg estimates Swift has made
$125 million over the years from record
sales she also made strong strategic
choices at the negotiating table in 2018
she left her longtime record label big
machine to go independent she negotiated
a new contract with Universal Music
Group in 2018 that allows her to take a
larger share of the royalties the
biggest part of her earnings is
undoubtedly her concert Revenue Taylor
Swift's concerts have generated at least
$1.6 billion and that is only ticket
sales as not including merchandise she's
done six tours over the years since 200
9 most recently the ays tour it came
right as everyone was starved for Live
Events people were coming out of the
pandemic and really wanted a chance to
gather in person and celebrate and there
are people that are willing to spend
anything and everything to get a chance
to see her a Splurge for sure but we're
glad to do it we've just been trying
without mortgaging the house uh of
course she doesn't keep all of that
money we estimate that Taylor Nets about
35% the ticket sales is profit about 500
million from touring over the years her
tours her record sales and streaming
royalties are all earnings but she also
has assets including her recording
catalog there's the Master's rights then
there's the publishing rights catalog is
a collection of songs all grouped under
one artist every time a song in this
catalog is played it generates a royalty
which goes back to the owner Swift
doesn't actually own the first six album
albums of her catalog it's now owned by
a fund called Shamrock Capital she's
re-recording those albums meaning she'll
get both more streaming revenue and a
more valuable catalog we estimate that
her catalog is worth about 400 million
then of course there's her actual
property that includes um a condo and an
estate in Nashville an estate in Los
Angeles a large apartment in Tribeca in
New York City as well as a summer house
in Rhode Island the Rhode Island
property is interesting cuz it's not
really a typical haunt for celebrities
or pop stars it's an oldw World sort of
old money part of the country but it is
kind of in keeping with Tor Swift's
image of this sort of girl next door a
little bit of a home body in fact she's
also has hosted fans there in the past
and baked them home baked cookies at
this property making bulk batches of
chocolate chip and toast to Coconut tur
for the the total value of her
properties is about 110
million subtract her expenses taxes
staff costs and so on and you get a net
worth of
$1.1
billion this was a huge year for Taylor
Swift that tipped her into a new Echelon
but with a 33-year-old having just set a
concert film record and the
international leg of her tour getting
underway she may only be getting
[Music]
started